Salut ! Aujourd'hui je réponds à l'une de vos demandes qui est comment est-ce qu'on peut engager la conversation ?
Ce n'est pas une demande que vous avez faites expressément comme ça, vous m'avez souvent demandé comment engager la conversation pour draguer,
comment dans un contexte professionnel vous pouviez aborder quelqu'un, ou comment dans votre vie sociale vous pouviez parler aux gens ?
Et bien je réponds à ces 3 questions en une seule vidéo ! Allez hop !
Générique !
[musique]
A vous les mentalos avec un "O", qui vous demandez comment engager la conversation.
J'y réponds, aujourd'hui en 5 astuces !
Première astuce, la plus évidente, mais on va quand même se la rappeler.
Quand vous devez engager la conversation avec quelqu'un, avec qu'une seule personne, n'ayez pas de préjugé.
N'ayez pas de crainte, ayez un sourire intérieur, mettez vous de bonne humeur.
Vous devez vous préparer mentalement à ne pas avoir de crainte à aller aborder la personne et à aller converser avec elle, elle est dans un bon état d'esprit.
Donc prenez le temps deux secondes de souffler, de vous préparer mentalement, et allez-y !
Deuxième astuce, ne cherchez pas à être pertinent.
Une de vos craintes vient du fait que vous vous dites "Ah... Est-ce que ça va être bien ce que je vais dire ?"
"Est-ce que ça va être intéressant ?"
J'ai un secret !
On s'en fout !
Vous allez aborder la personne et ça c'est le plus important.
Ne cherchez pas à être pertinent, soyez à la place contextuelle.
Et il y a des travaux ! C'est formidable chez moi !
Désolé pour le bruit de fond, ce n'est pas un truc que je maîtrise, et comme vous pouvez le constater,
il me reste 1H05 pour tout faire pour cette vidéo.
J'ai mis un petit peu de temps à l'écrire j'avoue.
Je disais donc, soyez contextuel et trouvez un prétexte pour parler à la personne.
Ça c'est plus intéressant.
Imaginons que vous êtes à une soirée, c'est un nouveau lieu qui vient d’être inauguré, vous pouvez aborder la personne tout simplement en allant la voir et en disant:
"Dis donc ils ont vraiment fait un truc incroyable, moi je ne m'attendais pas à ça !"
Et hop c'est parti !
La conversation elle démarre.
Prenez le contexte et retirez un prétexte pour aller aborder la personne.
Troisième astuce !
J'ai lu un jour dans le livre Best seller comment se faire des amis de Dale Carnegie, toute une phrase, une anecdote qu'elle a raconté.
Elle était allée dans une soirée et on lui a présenté quelqu'un de très cultivé, un médecin, etc.
et il lui a parlé toute la soirée.
C'est-à-dire qu'elle n'a pas parlé.
Elle l'a juste écouté.
Mais c'est tout.
Il y a rien de plus rien de moins.
De toute manière apparemment il abordait des sujets qu'elle ne maîtrisait pas du tout.
Et à la fin de la soirée, le docteur en question est allé voir l’hôte qui avait organisé tout ça, pour lui dire:
"Elle a une conversation incroyable et quelle culture ! C'était vraiment agréable, on a parlé ensemble toute la soirée." C'est faux.
C'est lui qui a parlé.
Mais dans son souvenir, elle avait une conversation passionnante.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'elle l'a écouté.
Donc on peut en retirer de cette troisième astuce fondamentale, une conversation nouvelle avec quelqu'un est plus intéressante pour ce quelqu'un
si vous vous mettez en situation d'écoute, plutôt qu'en situation de parler vous tout le temps.
Quatrième astuce, puisque vous allez l'écouter parler, vous allez pouvoir faire attention à son type de conversation.
Est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui va être plutôt rieur, est-ce que c'est quelqu'un de très sérieux.
Quelles métaphores la personne utilise pour s'exprimer, est-ce que c'est une personne plutôt qui se plaint de tout,
vous allez pouvoir vous rebondir là dessus et être dans la même énergie et être dans le même type de discussion, dans la même manière d'aborder les choses.
Donc vous allez être encore plus intéressant.
Posez lui quelques questions.
Vous pouvez aussi faire des relances, même quand vous ne maîtrisez pas du tout le sujet !
Grace à la magie de la reformulation !
Il y a pleins de types de reformulations possibles.
Deux sont très intéressantes.
La reformulation miroir. Si la personne est en train de parler vous dit: "J'ai fait un match de tennis là, et j'ai perdu... Mais d'habitude je ne perds pas !!!" [d'un ton énervé]
Votre reformulation ça peut être: "Ah d'accord, et donc tu joues au tennis ?! Mais apparemment tu as plutôt un bon niveau à la base ?"
C'est une reformulation miroir.
La reformulation empathique aussi.
Elle marche très très bien.
Vous allez juste faire une reformulation, mais non pas de ce qu'elle vient de dire mot pour mot mais de l'émotion qu'elle y a mis.
Imaginons la personne qui est en train de dire: "Et là je me suis fait volé mon téléphone portable, donc ça m'a obligé d'aller chercher des choses, des papiers, des déclarations de vols..."
"-Ha j'imagine que tu as du te sentir énervé de devoir faire tout ça, ça devait être très agaçant."
Voilà, c'est une relance de formulation empathique.
Mais dis donc, on ne serait pas en train d'arriver à la cinquième astuce ?!
La cinquième astuce elle se découpe en 5 points très rapides, mais gardez la en tête, c'est très très important.
C'est presque plus important que le reste, puisque ce sont les choses à ne pas faire. Donc cinquième astuce, évitez les pièges classiques.
En 1, la conversation ne doit pas devenir un interrogatoire non plus.
Faites des relances c'est bien. Posez des questions c'est bien. Mais ça ne doit pas être question, question, question, question, question, question, question tout le temps.
C'est très désagréable à vivre.
En 2, évitez toute plainte.
Vous ne devez pas être plaintif, ou énervé ou... même si la personne l'est, ça ce n'est pas le problème.
Vous restez toujours dans votre esprit positif, souriant et bienveillant quand vous parlez et quand vous parlez de vous, mais ne vous plaignez pas.
Troisièmement, évitez d'interrompre la personne quand elle parle.
Attendez vraiment que ce soit votre moment de parler.
Des fois on a un truc vraiment qu'on a envie de dire, mais si vous êtes dans cette démarche de rencontrer quelqu’un surtout pour la première fois,
faites très attention à ne pas l'interrompre.
En 4, ne tombez pas dans le paternalisme.
C'est la personne qui fait: "Oui, je comprends, mais moi je pense que tu devrais faire ça, parce que tu sais comment ça se passe, il faut faire ci comme ça, comme ça, comme ça, comme ça..."
Sur une première rencontre, ça peut vite soûler !
Et le cinquième point, on évite l'étalage.
Ne racontez pas votre vie.
N'oubliez pas que c'est vous qui êtes allé aborder la personne, on ne vous a rien demandé au départ.
Donc n'étalez pas comme ça votre CV, votre vie, tout ça c'est assez désagréable aussi, même si la personne sourit, en réalité son discours intérieur peut être tout autre.
Ils y en a qui piègent comme ça, qui font des prises d'otages de conversation.
Ils arrivent vers toi, ils te posent 2 questions, 3 questions, et une fois que tu as répondu, ils estiment qu'ils ont le droit à 30 minutes de temps de parole, pas d'étalage.
J'espère qu'avec ces 5 points vous allez pouvoir aborder la conversation dans tous types de situations.
Que ce soit pourtour pas dans de la séduction,  dans le travail, dans les relations sociales classiques...
Et que ça va vous faciliter la vie.
Si la vidéo vous a plu, vous savez ce que vous avez à faire. Il parait qu'il ne faut pas le dire, alors je ne le dis pas...
Voilà. Mais vous le faites que si ça vous a plu évidemment.
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir, ça c'est très important si vous ne l'avez pas déjà fait.
Et sinon le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
AH NON !
J'ai dit une bêtise !
Demain on est samedi, donc rendez-vous demain à 11H, et ouais les mecs on se réveille demain !
Ciao !
[musique]